[Aplausos]
eu penso que eu seja um pouco como a
vida você tem um propósito você vai
adaptar sua vida para chegar lá
[Música]
com o vento a favor tudo foi bem não é a
sensação do mundo
o diretor do vento muda um teórico nem
pai
[Música]
quando as condições não estão a favor
quando a vontade de fazer mais
impulsiona porque eu sempre gosto e
somente quem tiver bem preparados e acha
a sua vitória
mais ou menos como a vida é isso né
vamos falar um pouco da vida então eu
comecei a viajar os 13 anos com a irmã
que foi minha grande inspiração porque
ela é muito dedicada muito empenhados em
aprender o esporte e eu na verdade ava
eu já vi um vento forte odiava água fria
eu odiava agressividade do vento e lugar
onde a gente aprendeu a velejar uma
lagoa pequenininha muito surge então não
gostava de praga onde tenho mas com
muita insistência por parte da minha
irmã por parte da minha mãe e do nosso
professor na época enganei e já com 15
anos
eu corri meu primeiro campeonato
internacional e foi terceiro no mundial
júnior e foi um campeonato muito
especial para mim porque eu competi com
a minha irmã e minha mãe nos acompanhou
então foi muito legal é o campeonato que
eu me lembre com mais carinho
pouco tempo depois a gente conhece o
campeonato a escolinha a gente aprendeu
fechou ea gente foi então corretor iate
clube do rio de janeiro que oferece uma
estrutura muito mais profissional pra
gente
meu primeiro técnico lucas foi
contratado pelo clube e ele por sua vez
nos forçou a contratar por conta própria
o protecionismo preparador físico uma
equipe que me desce os treinos de
bicicleta para fazer toda a partir da
preparação física bem arrumada e pouco
depois de descer pro desse trabalho como
técnico começar eu já vivi em 2008
entrando na abertura das olimpíadas de
pequim e foi muito especial eu lembro de
passar por baixo do túnel que dava no
estádio da abertura e gritar em coro com
toda a delegação brasileira eu sou
brasileiro
isso foi muito especial e como eu era
atleta mais nova delegação de vela
o pessoal da da equipe de vela me elegeu
para ser o porta-bandeira da semana de
abertura que ela nossa cidadezinha em
dau
então foi muito legal essa olimpíada pra
mim eu pude competir com as minhas
ídolos no esporte
a bárbara que anda alessandra sensini e
meu pai meu irmão estavam lá me dando
força também então maggi na china
em 2008 não era essa potência que a
gente conhece hoje em dia ela estava se
abrindo para o mundo então foi uma vida
completamente megalomaníaco e muito
especial é ao longo do meu da minha
carreira como treinador
como atleta eu passei por três gestões
de federação diferentes e quando uma
dessas gestões mudou eles chamaram e se
meu técnico para trabalhar com eles e
foi a primeira vez que a fifa de
técnicos mas como ainda estava no embalo
da das olimpíadas eu continuei treinando
por conta própria
eu treinava de manhã tomava banho estava
correndo e eu própria faculdade
às vezes dormia jesus mas gerar o aluno
e conseguiu fazer os dois ao mesmo tempo
foi só em 2011 quando eu ganhei minha
primeira medalha pan-americana que eu
ganhei então a atenção do comitê
olímpico brasileiro que resolveu abraçar
o meu projeto e eles então mudar uma
estrutura mais profissional de
preparação física nutricionista
fisioterapeuta mas mesmo assim o
problema do técnico continua pendente é
o windsurf não é um esporte popular no
brasil né a gente a cultura náutica no
brasil é muito incipiente então a
especialidade de técnico de windsurf
não existe o que aconteceu foi que muito
muito tempo trabalhei com o técnico de
barco vela e eu treinava eles ou
construir junto com eles um trabalho
direcionado para mim surf
a maioria dos mil tec dos meus técnicos
sequer o número já é de muito surf e
vocês vejam com 15 anos de carreira como
atleta profissional que comprou comprou
esse ano eu tive 12 técnicos da minha
vida
isso é quase um por ano né é muita gente
na verdade essa rotatividade enorme de
treinadores
foi o meu primeiro pai minha primeira
peça do quebra-cabeça eu tive que
aprender a construir a própria campanha
gerir a própria campanha os
profissionais que trabalhavam comigo nós
fisioterapeutas nutricionistas é ter por
conta própria e criar no próprio
metodologia de trabalho
então na verdade eu construir esse tempo
todo que eu trabalhei com tantos
técnicos eu fui aprendendo muitos
exercícios e também o intercâmbio com
técnicos os gringos e tal e aí eu fiz um
livrinho com todos os exercícios que eu
conhecia todos os treinos que eu
conhecia com anotações técnicas com o
vento soprar o vento era para o
exercício como era a periodização e eu
ganhei muita autonomia fazendo isso pra
ganhar tempo na verdade a cada vez que
eu iniciasse o trabalho com o treinador
novo em vez de perder três meses
treinando caram se entregava um livrinho
aprende aí a gente se vê nada amanhã é
isso fui muito bem recebido por um juiz
não tão bem recebido por outro porque
afinal de contas eram técnicos
experientes e alguns defendiam como ele
vive
mas foi uma primeira peça do
quebra-cabeça eu assumi essa gente tão
pra mim e gerar meu próprio metodologia
de trabalho
isso que é muito alta confiança nessa
pegada acreditar que aquilo que está
fazendo com 23 anos réu certa é só que
essa ao mesmo tempo que você é gestor do
seu próprio da sua própria campanha você
agrega muita pressão sobre você mesmo
nessa acaba não podendo compartilhar
muito com as vezes o técnico que não tá
lá então isso foi gerando muito estresse
eu comecei a ficar com muita ansiedade e
continuando sempre estava fazendo
caminho certo
será que as minhas escolhas de
pelotização as setas como é que será que
os ingleses fazia conexão é que os
franceses faziam e os chineses que tinha
muito mais dinheiro
isso vai gerando muito stress nos jogos
olímpicos do rio
eu comecei a trabalhar com um treinador
muito bom neozelandês é apenas um
semestre antes das olimpíadas
então a gente chegou nas olimpíadas
nunca trabalha ainda assim terminando e
ganhou a olimpíada nesse nível de
destreza s de saber que nosso trabalho
estava bem encaminhado mas que precisava
de um pouquinho mais de tempo mas a
gente conseguiu trabalhar assim a
experiência da limpeza do rio é uma é
uma dicotomia sim por um lado
muito especial está com a torcida toda
do meu lado a família meus amigos
fizeram uma blusa time pat
isso foi muito legal muito especial só
que por outro lado como eu moro no rio
eu nunca saí daquele ambiente de
olimpíada né eu saí do meu treino
chegava em casa e pessoal queria saber
como estão tendo como é que as
preparações
essa é para o natal na família e como
estão os treinos e temos aqui
isso é muito difícil controlar assim
sair desse meio de olimpíada era muito
difícil e acabou que eu cheguei no
olímpico assim já muito cansadas sobre
aquele mesmo assunto de olimpíadas
sempre mas mesmo assim eu fui oitavo
lugar que é o melhor resultado feminino
na história e eu fiquei feliz com esse
resultado e até hoje não fico tentando
repetir assim a olimpíada foi boa pra
mim foi muito boa mas aí foi pesada né
e foi aí que descobri a segunda peça do
quebra-cabeça como estava o tempo todo
viajando sob tanta pressão eu esqueci
que o projeto na verdade era meu era meu
pra mim mesmo né
eu tinha entregado as rédeas do meu
projeto para a federação para cometer
pro meu técnico e perdi a paixão que era
o que a minha a minha razão inicial para
começar no esporte porque eu gostava
daquilo eu me vi sendo obrigado a fazer
aquilo pra querer provar resultados dos
outros né pra conseguir manter o
investimento não sei quê
e aí me dei conta de que em sendo assim
não ia funcionar que eu estava ali
correndo atrás me esforçando dando o
sangue na regata tinha que ser um
negócio pra mim porque eu queria porque
eu tinha que assumir na própria
narrativa e é um negócio meu projeto
pessoal era minha verdade ea minha
versão da história que eu precisava
contar e essa foi a segunda peça do
quebra-cabeça e agora está em campanha
para toc 2020 e com muito mais
maturidade e experiência
eu pretendo encarar esse caminho sabendo
que até lá eu vou encontrar muitas
outras peças do quebra-cabeça e chegar a
uma olimpíada
lena e espero com chance correndo
muito obrigada gente
[Música]
[Aplausos]